hello i heard you wanted to be
a live streamer there are loads of
different streamers out there
you have your just chatters your artists
your animators your musicians
and of course your gamers but there are
even different types of
gamers when you have your seriously
skilled gamers
and you have your more relaxed gamers
now i'm stuck and then you even have
your community-focused gamers go fast
what kind of live streamer do you want
to be this video
will give you some tips on how to set up
for a live stream the equipment
that you might need and also some tips
on how to start so who am i
and what kind of live streamer am i well
i'm a bit offended that you can't tell
right now because
obviously i'm a skills game come on come
on come on come on
come on come here they come and go
i don't know which button because i
press x
oh my god i'm actually getting wrecked
what the hell no i
guess i would say i'm more community
focused
[Music]
what's up gamers this is the equipment
that i used
to make my high quality live streams for
you all
it might surprise you to hear that you
don't necessarily need a high-end pc to
start streaming
i use a dell inspiron gaming laptop and
i also don't have a webcam yet
so instead i use my samsung note 9
and the android app droid cam okay so my
setup it probably isn't the best that
you've ever seen
but it is getting better and that's the
main thing and i just want to take this
moment to say thank you to
blue microphones for partnering with me
as a part of their take the leap
and power by blue campaign i've
personally been using blue microphones
for years and have always found them to
be really
great quality and they've sent over a
logitech
pro x wireless headset which is so
comfortable and means that i can stream
for longer without being
in pain and hearing my game audio
nice and clearly and here's a word from
blue microphones there's no doubt
it starts with a spark of inspiration to
come up for something new and
share it with the world to tell your
unique story and connect with others
to make a positive impact and bring
people closer together whether you're
recording a podcast
filming a youtube video or simply live
streaming
blue microphones will help your message
cut through the noise
sleek stylish and easy to use blue
microphones makes it easy
to capture crystal clear broadcast sound
even if you're just getting started
let's blue connect your inspiration
to your audience because they know how
important
it is to have good audio that's my setup
but back to you so ask yourself why do
you want to stream
imagine your amazing setup that will be
so
much better than mine your high-end
equipment
your amazing gaming pc all these led
lights everywhere and now
chuck that out the window just chuck it
out the window to be a live streamer
you must learn humility a lot of the
time especially when you
start off live streaming you're gonna
get so many things wrong
and it's going to go wrong live
when you're being watched by people and
that can be pretty embarrassing
i honestly believe there's no point
waiting until you have your perfect
setup with all your great equipment
this setup that i have right now it's
still not complete no
but it's so much better than where it
was when i started live streaming
because i actually started live
streaming on my playstation
4.
you don't even need a pc to be a live
streamer
i did it through my playstation 4 with
the playstation camera and
that was that you could hook up a
microphone to it if you wanted to be
a little bit more crisp at the end of
the day what you need to
get better out initially anyway is
communicating with people online with
your chat
and feeling comfortable in front of the
camera ready if you're not a youtuber
or anything like that it is a weird
thing to get used to talking to a camera
especially
when there's no one there if you see
that zero in the view count
it can be pretty disheartening and then
you feel like you don't want to
perform or entertain but you must just
get used to doing it no matter what that
view count is because
when people jump in you have a few
seconds to
grab their attention so you don't need a
great setup
to start practicing that right now but
saying that it is ready to know where
you're aiming for in the future so don't
forget that
wonderful view of your amazing setup and
all of the people watching your stream
and how great it's gonna be
once you get there okay the next
question i'm gonna ask you is
what do you want to stream this kind of
ties back nicely
to the question that i asked you
previously of why do you want to stream
and if you initially thought that you
want
money and fame and to be well known
then good on you but this will
impact on what you stream because you
will have to find your niche and you'll
have to look at live streaming
in more of a business sense you'll have
to carve out a path for yourself
and build up a dedicated audience that
are expecting
the same thing over and over so they'll
always
be wanting to come back because they'll
know what to expect from you
of course you can also build up a great
audience with your personality i'm not
saying that you can't it's just a lot
harder so if you build up a presence
around
a game that you're playing a lot say
overwatch
i mean fortnite is the obvious one or a
new game
that has come out and not as many live
streamers are playing
that's how you will grow an audience
fast with that in mind though i would
like to just say that once you have that
audience who knows you for something
that you've done whether that be a
certain game or even
a certain category it's hard to break
out of that it's hard to
go and do something else because your
audience
expects that thing from you
and there have been certain instances of
well-known
live streamers trying to branch out to
something else because they've gotten
bored of what they're doing
and ultimately getting very negative
reactions from the audiences so just
think about that
are you doing it for purely enjoyment or
are you doing it
in a business sense to try and grow
a platform and make a name for yourself
there is a possibility you can do both
but ultimately no matter what you choose
please play something that you enjoy
it's very obvious you can play something
very popular
and of course that will probably help
boost your view count
but if it's popular and someone else is
playing it and they obviously enjoy it
more than you
people aren't going to stick around so
play something that you
love that you enjoy that you genuinely
have fun with
and your viewers will have fun watching
you and the great thing about being a
new streamer
and having hardly anyone watching is
that you get to experiment
experiment with different games with
even different categories
and see what feels right for you and
then once you find
your niche or your flow or you decide
heck i'm just going to do something
different each time because that's what
makes me
happiest then you can start going
and make a schedule for that
and schedules are very important i will
just put it out there try
and stream as often as you can i stream
once a week and that's not enough
now once you've decided what kind of
streams you want to do
you'll know where you want to invest in
your equipment
and your software for example if you
decide that you're a musician
and you want to sing or if you just want
to do
chill chatting with your community on
live streams
you will definitely want to invest in a
better camera and better audio equipment
because essentially
that's all that people are going to see
your lovely face
and that booming voice gamers on the
other hand
depending on what types of games you
want to play you might want to buy a
capture card so you can
capture your switch or your playstation
and of course
better pc equipment it's always good
make it run smoother all streamers
however will need
some sort of broadcasting software so
you can capture the video inputs and the
audio inputs
and output it to the live stream
platform of your choice the most popular
one
is obs and i personally use streamlabs
obs
it's an extension of obs but it comes
with
alerts and overlays and
themes which make it really easy to set
up
a really nice looking stream you can
also use streamlabs to set up timed
comments
to give your viewers a random compliment
every 20 minutes
i personally have one and it says hey
you you're cute and i think that's great
once you've set up uh your broadcasting
software with
the oh what's it called once you've set
up
all of your video inputs and audio
inputs into your broadcasting software
it's really easy then to just use a
stream key to
set up and stream it to your platform of
choice
but what is your platform of choice
where do you stream
twitch youtube mixer facebook live there
are so
many options and i know it can get very
overwhelming i felt it too when i first
started live streaming
all i can say to this is do a bit of
research oh well that's not all i can
say so why have i written that in the
script
i can say way more than that messy do a
bit of research for yourself
because they all have unique benefits
twitch for example
has a lot of integration in with
games so that the community can get
involved while you play certain games
and also
trigger off overlays and alerts and
things like that
way more than another platform such as
youtube can do
however youtube is primarily used for
video
content not so much live streaming
content
so there's way higher chance of people
still viewing your live streams even
after it's ended so your view count will
still be going up it's completely
up to you but i would personally say to
choose a platform
where you feel most drawn to as a viewer
because you're more likely to feel more
comfortable there and also you would
understand
the platform and the audiences a lot
better
because you're already a part of it but
saying all that
if you're really indecisive like me
you can actually use restream using
restream
you can stream to multiple different
platforms at the same time
i use this to stream to both youtube and
twitch
because my audience are primarily on
youtube
but i know some people like to watch me
on twitch as well hey i guess i'm just
the people please
but do bear in mind that if you do this
then you will not be eligible to become
a twitch affiliate or a twitch partner
and start making money through that way
because they ask for live content
exclusivity at the end of the day
live streaming is about forming
connections with people all around the
world
and sharing with them things that you're
passionate about
that's a bit creepy i believe if you
stay true to who you are
and what you're passionate about then
you're bound to have a really
positive experience through live
streaming i obviously have to make a
little disclaimer saying you know
it's live be careful what you say have
some fun but keep
in mind that you're you're being watched
by multiple eyes which actually
is a little bit scary um but ultimately
it brings you together with people that
you would have never
met otherwise or even heard of
and i think that's the really nice thing
about live streaming
but then again i am just you know a big
mushy slop of
uh mushtop so i know i kind of breezed
through a lot of that especially with
the um equipment
and software side because i just wanted
to try and
condense everything down into questions
that you could ask yourself to then go
away
and do more research but if you do want
me to go through
something in more detail please leave me
a comment down
below i want to help as many of you guys
as i can i'm not a massive streamer
no but i have been doing it for quite a
while and
i enjoy it so maybe i can help you guys
cool
have a lovely day or evening bye